[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey everybody here we are we might be
drunk good to have you Sam's hung over
Stevo sober and uh we lost the Peruvian
dog you found that dog in Peru I did and
uh
I was videoing as I found her like I
approached her with the camera rolling
and I just kept filming the whole time I
was in Peru this is where I found her on
the streets of Peru and I put together
this video about how we fell in love and
how I brought her home with me to
America and that [ __ ] video got more
views than anything I've ever put on the
Internet it's that's the Internet it's a
slippery [ __ ] she can't predict it yeah
well you never know I'll tell you it was
that that dog's a slippery [ __ ] ran
away from us yeah it was a real kick in
the nuts to learn that after a lifetime
of attention whoring exactly just
couldn't come up with a goddamn thing
better than rescuing a dog you put a Hot
Wheel car up your ass
you can't beat it that's those are the
things you think of that pop though on
like Tick Tock or YouTube it's like
self-harm yeah animals right yeah I mean
anything animal cats my girls in the cat
stuff and that all just blows up yeah my
girl actually uh just Scrolls and
Scrolls and Scrolls nothing but animals
wow yeah there you go because you know
what there's so much hatred and vitriol
just being spewed on Twitter and all
this [ __ ] and then you see a little cat
and you're like oh the world's not right
awful yeah kind of nice for bestiality
people because they're like oh I love
animals you know you have it out that's
kind of convenient I never thought about
that ah man Dad I'm a fan
bestiality
hey you think that does well just a
rescuing a dog yeah [ __ ] a dog that's
going through the roof yeah yeah I mean
you guys uh gave me this annoying
homework you know all this different
stuff think about how do we let's do a
bit about [ __ ] a dog
I tried to write a bit years ago about
how we make fun of bestiality people but
we we talk about women as if they're
animals she's a fox she's a hot chick
that's a cougar or if she's ugly that's
a dog she's a pig we always go back to
animal right okay Russ minivus have a
great bit where he said uh doggy style
that's too kinky for me I like human
style that's when I put my dog on his
back
that's a great great little mystery
great Russell Peters Richmond Eve oh
okay I was gonna say Russell Peters that
doesn't involve an ethnic person or an
accent
um yeah man so you're in New York just
just hanging promoting my book that's
right the book yeah I I have a book it's
my second book it's called A Hard kick
in the nuts New York Time Best Seller I
sure hope so yeah it would be uh I would
be mortified if it's not but um we don't
receive official word about that for
another uh presumably a week uh-huh do
you have did you ever think you would
write one book much less too I did I did
I'm such a rabbit attention [ __ ] and
always have been that I kind of just
viewed my life as uh
something that I was doing so that it
would be a really crazy book hell yeah
wow you got everything what I've learned
from a lifetime of terrible decisions
yeah I love them wisdom
unfortunately Memoir part two I learned
is not a thing
right so you got it you gotta have some
kind of an angle on it so uh I went with
a book of wisdom gleaned from a lifetime
of terrible decisions yeah is that part
of your sobriety
is that is what part of my support the
bad decisions I I have managed to make
awful decisions in sobriety yeah that's
impressive yeah for sure I I love it I
love a good bad decision I know but the
sobriety part sucks you can't blame it
on drugs or booze you know that's it you
know like the the book has its uh it's
fun it's funny and it's serious as well
and and uh that plays into the serious
part that uh it's a [ __ ] when
you're a piece of [ __ ] and you don't
have drugs and alcohol to blame yeah
that's hard did you do the whole rehab
thing or did you just oh yeah oh you did
I did I did
um it started the sobriety started with
an intervention which was uh organized
and led by Johnny Knoxville oh it's the
funniest intervention of all time that
was one of my first jokes uh you know in
stand up was uh you know you've got a
problem when your interventionist is
Johnny Knox hey right you walk in a
bucket of waterfalls on your head come
on come on man we need to talk
yeah
wow so what what was the drug of choice
uh I was uh what we were referred to as
a garbage can
um so that's everything fairly
non-discriminate I never uh did heroin
and I never smoked crack hmm but other
than that I was uh indiscriminate never
really got into meth but at the same
time I never turned it down I gotcha
that's pretty good I feel like you know
there's a lot of crack head Comedians
and actors and then heroin you never did
that I think you're doing all right
right that was what I learned from my
first time in rehab in 1995. oh you
multiple times yeah 1995 I was only 20
years old I was on a string of bad luck
yeah I ended up in rehab totally by
mistake and what I learned in there was
Wow crack is bad
so is heroin yeah David Cross talked
about doing crack in his book and he
said like I did it once or twice never
did it again but he gets why it's so
popular he's like you feel great I mean
I I understand it is absolutely
delicious yeah crack is great practice
like kind of no that's tough I mean
that's uh you see people on the street
and you're like well you're not doing
great advertising for crack right right
you know or math or whatever I mean I
don't like drugs where you're just
always on the drug uh I like that moment
with hangovers you're like I am a piece
of [ __ ] I hate myself let me text a
friend the dude who's on meth is not
waking up the next day like did I almost
Rob and rape someone last night if you
don't have that Moment of clarity yeah
you just keep going yeah that's got to
be tough yeah I remember uh that that
first career habit it was always
everybody was in a circle sharing their
feelings yep and on just about every day
there was somebody who left and somebody
who arrived and the the rival entailed
walking up to the circle and introducing
yourself and stating what your drug of
choice was okay and I really quickly got
the impression that whenever anybody
said their drug of choice was crack
everybody's priority was making sure
that that [ __ ] person was not their
roommate whoa whoa I don't think they
would have heard eye contact like I
don't want like why is that because just
coming off it was a nightmare
um that and uh just like I it's a bad
personality type just a bad person that
I don't want to have to deal with you
hear that Tom Sizemore it's a piece of
[ __ ] he was a crackhead
and I also I got the sense that when
people's drug of choice was heroin they
didn't walk up to the circle they were
more like kind of carried into the
internet and then we would meet them in
a couple days right right they were
zombie wow that's crazy so it's like the
movie is with the circle and the it was
a very first lady did you share your
feelings even as a 20 year old yeah I
remember then I would always introduce
myself as I'm Stevo and I'm an alcoholic
I knew you though yeah oh that's even
weirder oh no no they didn't know me in
1995. okay but I but I was introduced
myself as Stevo got it got it yeah now
I'm a little bit more uh
I I I try not to be Stevo in those
circles and and the the recovery
Community out of respect I feel like
sure you're not supposed to use a stage
name yeah I'm the amazing Jonathan
all right exactly that's uh that's
fascinating that you went at such a
young age
it didn't stick it didn't stick back
then if you can believe it it uh it was
um when I was 33 that I got sober okay
that's pretty good really [ __ ] good
man yeah congrats that's the thing
that's the thing with addiction is that
uh
it's a [ __ ] if you just kinda
have it if you're say if you're an
alcoholic but not it's not so bad yeah
you know it can continue yeah it just
kind of turns into quicksand it it just
slows you down it [ __ ] up your
relationships it precludes you from like
really realizing your potential right
but it's not so bad that it needs to be
addressed so it just continues and
continues in the Years turn into decades
and then the next thing you know you're
an old dude and you're just [ __ ]
sitting there and like [ __ ] I blew it so
true yeah when it eats away at just a
little it's almost worse than if you
have a rock bottom moment oh my God I'm
so fortunate that I had it so goddamn
bad I was just like it was so not okay
the way I was carrying on that it had to
be addressed and so
you know it's the only disease like
where you become a better version of
yourself any other disease the best you
can hope for is to be restored to the
health you enjoyed before you got sick
right but when when we treat alcoholism
and addiction we actually become a
better version of ourselves than we ever
were before Thursday it's Unique in that
way because you think the Gratitude as
well I think the Gratitude I think that
uh that um you know it's it's like a
spiritual solution you know we kind of
get plugged in we we make sure we're
doing the right thing when nobody's
watching that's like the big deal what
about sex addict that's a tough one it's
a tough one yeah it's a tough one but I
would I would maintain uh the same thing
if anything I think uh the sex addict is
almost um
almost a heightened example of that
because uh because say when you bounce
back from the kind of Shame and and
guilt you know like that that can be
associated with sex addiction then
you're coming out of that with like a
level of humility and you know right and
uh like Precision Care for doing the
right thing when yeah I think most guys
think they're a sex addict but then they
come and they're like I'm not you know
like I've had that thought like maybe
I'm addicted then it's like no of course
I mean you actually but it did it go
hand in hand with the other addictions I
once said like my life played out at
like sort of an addiction whack-a-mole
you know a game of whack-a-mole like one
you know address one thing and the other
thing is rears right yeah you know like
I I had to address the sex stuff
um when I was well into sobriety yeah
and uh and that was that that was
crucial man and maybe look if you think
about it like
um as far as like Falls from Grace you
know like just absolute like Devastation
of people's uh careers their reputation
is livelihood very little competes with
sex as far as just taking down huge oh
for sure people for sure Armie Hammer
yeah he's gone that's a bummer what
about food addict is tough too because
you have to eat you don't have to do
heroin you have to stay alive so that's
a bummer that's where I'm at now the guy
you got food
I'm in and out of the food thing I'm
dude I've never uh appeared to be
somebody who's uh like got a problem
with with food but man uh Sugar's a
[ __ ] it really is I remember
when the uh the Joaquin Phoenix Joker
movie came out this is I'm thinking like
uh he's in it ah dude epic I'm thinking
it was like 2019 when it came out yeah
like um I sat in that [ __ ] theater
with an entire tub of caramel popcorn
and a jumbo pack of [ __ ] Red Vines
and I I sat there and like took a huge
bite of Red Vines and then as I chewed
it like filled my mouth with caramel pie
chew it all in concerts
yeah and and I found it to be the most
[ __ ] delicious [ __ ] I've ever eaten
and I did not stop until I'd eaten the
entire tub of wow and the whole jumbo
pack of Red Vines and I was like I have
a problem you know so it's crazy to be
watching that guy on screen you'd be
like I'm sick I've got problems Phoebe
Herman's next you go on this guy
together that guy got a bum Brad yeah he
did our board theater our boy Ronan has
a great joke about it we owe him a big
apology because he was doing exactly we
were supposed to be doing you know in
that movie theater right right a hundred
percent yeah that's but that I get I
mean the sugar addiction like you feel
the sugar high sometimes sometimes I'm
trying to behave on the road like Mark
and I are well behaved drinkers so
that's it is a problem
I mean to be fair let's not characterize
you guys as having alcoholism a little
bit right I mean it's sort of either
have alcoholism or you don't and it
seems evident to me that you guys are
not having problems you know it's
affecting stuff
beat my ex no
it's all it's all uh you know degrees
and levels sure yeah I think it's it's
evident to me that you guys are
functioning at a very high level and
that nothing I was saying about
quicksand applies to you guys oh geez I
definitely heard that I was like that
might be yeah I had a late night and I'm
definitely one of those people that like
my friend text me he's like that was so
fun last night and I was like I was
[ __ ] wasted and then he was like you
were like you could and I'm like oh
that's not good well that's not good
better than you were there
I wasn't like I was I was I just thought
I blacked out but I was like oh I was
drunk right sure whoa [ __ ] where were
you I didn't see you uh I didn't see you
I canceled spots oh well there you go I
need a night off yeah I get it I've been
burning the road hard we go hard on the
road yeah I was hearing I was hearing
that like five different spots a night
yeah at a certain point it's not even
helping though at a certain point you're
like what are we doing yeah definitely
not I mean I believe strongly in doing
10 10 minute spots when I'm putting a
show together yeah you know like right
now I'm in the in the swing of a tour
the last [ __ ] thing I wanted just to
do you know small sets at a low you know
like I'm not hurting for stage time at
all I'm [ __ ] touring my dick off yeah
and uh soon enough I will be um you know
putting together the chunks of of the
next hour nice man you're in the
Midnight Oil you got a hot sauce a book
a podcast and you're on the road and you
have a dog yeah the butthole Destroyer
hot sauce yeah that's my new and hotter
version of Stevo's hot sauce for your
butthole I just put a drip of it on my
wrap and it smells really good check out
the top three ingredients oh here we go
fentanyl
wow and Chili Peppers wow good band uh
scorpion
yeah the top three ingredients are the
three hottest peppers in the world
Carolina Reaper
the technical term for ghost pepper oh
really wow Carolina Reaper chili Reaper
Carolina Reaper is the hottest so this
will [ __ ] you up
it's designed to [ __ ] you up yeah it was
hot I put a dab in it there's this guy
named Johnny Scoville on the internet oh
I know it's Google he [ __ ] chugs an
entire goddamn bottle of that [ __ ] chugs
the whole thing and he's just sitting
there chilling unreal and spicy it's
it's really spicy but it's really it's
good it's really good well thank you a
dash on your eggs might be nice very
good yeah whenever I'm out of the
original Stevo's hot sauce for your
butthole yeah that's the only time I use
this [ __ ] and when I use this [ __ ] I'm
so careful and I'm poor tiny drops oh
yeah what about the uh have you done hot
ones I have I've done it a couple times
that guy can take some heat
he can I uh you think you're tougher I
don't think I'm tougher
um I do think that they are a little bit
um that they could go hotter on that
shot oh really really I do believe
that's the case I don't know maybe I'm
wrong a lot but I love that [ __ ] guy
Sean Evans yeah great great interview I
love that [ __ ] guy I love that show
to this day my most reviewed interview
I've ever done I believe is my first hot
ones oh nice it's amazing how everyone
tries to come up with these crazy ideas
and then you're like we eat hot wings
that's the shock yeah that's it it's
amazing too how the format endures you
would think that it would be like kind
of get played out you know like they
just do the same [ __ ] thing and and
uh but we like seeing people in weird
because like it's fun seeing Paul Rudd
like oh God I'm dying here you know
because you never get to see they're
always cool as a cucumbers it's
vulnerable it's a horrible thing right I
remember my first time on there was like
so determined I knew it had a huge
audience I knew that Kevin Hart had done
it before me I knew that I was like man
I'm gonna be talking to a lot of people
when I do this interview and like I was
just belligerently refusing to let the
heat of the Wings preclude me from
communicating effectively hell yeah I
thought through it and that just fine
yeah and then after I was done I went
and took a piss in some bushes and my
dick was on foot that's yeah because you
touched the wings you got to dip it in
oat milk or something my dick was
burning like a [ __ ] because I
took a piss in some bushes after you
like the chlamydia's back
wow what is I'm fascinated by the sex
addiction that what is like rock bottom
with a sex addiction look like oh man do
you [ __ ] a cantaloupe and you're like I
can't keep doing it what is this that's
the case I'm I'm going to rehab tomorrow
every object in my home as a child
do that a couch yeah I did it all right
I mean sister grandma would come over
like don't sit there don't sit there
yeah exactly and uh I mean it depends
man in general like that I would say the
definition of addiction is when uh you
continue a behavior despite there being
serious consequences for the behavior
and uh you know and with sex addiction I
think more often than not the
consequences are just generally shame
you know like you're like you are
ashamed of yourself and and you just
hate the way it feels and you keep doing
it anyway you know yeah my particular
pattern
uh you know was was involved like really
pouring on the charm to get like a a
woman really into me and then like just
try to you know acting out sexually and
then losing interest and ghosting you
know it's just like there's this
terrible uh
kind of sociopathic pattern of just like
routinely harming people right that that
it just made me feel like the [ __ ]
worst piece of [ __ ] ever especially when
they're like hey what are you doing
you're like oh I'm done with you already
right yeah right for sure and you know
and like the the constant anxiety of
like the the health risks Associated
sure that's [ __ ] up you weren't
wearing a condom either that was really
pretty damn good about it about about
you know acting out sexually are you
more scared of STDs are knocking someone
up
um but I was way more scared of STDs I
would agree you can get rid of a baby
get rid of herpes
some of those States is a little harder
that's true that's a tougher phone call
Missouri than uh you know yeah rather
than but there were exceptions man you
know there was you know there's one
particularly horrifying story that I
recount in in my new book which I'm
super reluctant to share right now
because my fiance is sitting up oh hello
but um but you know and and I had told
this the same story on Marc maron's what
the [ __ ] podcast like years ago okay and
um and and all of a sudden I just had
this [ __ ] panic attack and reached
out to the producers of Marc maron's
podcast saying please please [ __ ] cut
out that that story I told about about
so and so right and then I went and put
it in the book and what what it was
smart was uh
it I mean really then and it's it's
basically the answer to the Rock Bottom
question you know it it was it was one
of those exceptions to the rule where I
was having unprotected sex and um
it was a a situation where
um I I had uh you know the the this
woman I met on tour and we arranged her
to fly in she was like she was staying
with me for like I don't know like four
or five days wow that we were like
there's the exception of the rule just
going and going ahead and having
unprotected sex yep and about halfway
through the visit she said she just
casually tells me
that her uh
her last relationship was with the guy
whose last relationship was with a guy
and I'm like oh [ __ ] okay so now I just
landed in the [ __ ] highest possible
risk category for HIV oh wow you know
like it's like like her last partner was
a dude who has sex with dudes which is
like by Far and Away the highest risk
category I'm freaking the [ __ ] out
uh-huh yeah and I mean I'm just not okay
I remember like as soon as she said this
I was like oh I gotta go walk the dogs
or you know I'm [ __ ] walk in the
doctor I'm freaking out I'm Googling the
experience the scariest statistics you
know and when I get back to the
apartment I'm like
well like you know I I already did it
you know like oh yeah might as well live
with it my one I already did it you know
there's no like you might as well do it
again and that was that was the moment
where I'm like what the [ __ ] oh wow what
you know like like what the [ __ ] am I
doing yeah and I was just like that that
was literally it's literally like you
got poison you're like I'm gonna finish
the dish
yeah exactly I mean that's that's how
[ __ ] up it was and that was
specifically I remember like I I I I
drove that girl to the airport so that
she could fly home and I went like
racing to the doctor's office like oh my
God like [ __ ] I need to be and um and
and it died in equal
swiftness reached out to somebody I knew
who was in the sex program and it was
like dude like enough is enough man I I
need [ __ ] help and that was uh that
was where the journey began so how is it
living with AIDS
fortunately I've uh I've been tested uh
many many times in the years since that
happened and uh seem to have gotten away
with it hell yeah yeah a heist so it was
a uh a uh
not an expensive lesson there is a a
valuable lesson not a costly one there
you go yeah that's uh and then there we
have it my girl is sitting over there
now like uh the the scary part of the
book that she's afraid to read she
doesn't have to read it she's heard it
now hey there you go
oh I did you were drunk
I've told that story before how about
that I did not know that I honestly
thought that you were hearing that for
the first time
there you go okay how about that I got
points for being considerate yeah yeah
that's uh that's a addiction is tough
man I mean you tell that story and I'm
like oh man that's uh like I I feel the
shame like I understand hey this is
weird I mean it's got to be crazy you
walking into like a clinic though and
they're like is that [ __ ] Stevo
or they're like that's [ __ ] the dude
from Jackass yeah
I remember the it's like the really
weirdly like the the one doctor that uh
there were a couple times I went running
to this talk she's like dude ah you know
and the doctor is a gastroenterologist
who is the the one doctor that I have
like a like a an ongoing and regular
relationship with because I have a an
esophageal condition called Barrett's
esophagus okay which is legitimately
scary it
um it's often uh like develops into like
esophageal cancer and so like it's kind
of a precursor to esophageal cancer and
as such needs to be like really closely
monitored so I'd get what's called
endoscopies where they put a camera down
and check it out it's since become a
stable Condition it's not like it
they're like oh you're good like no more
endoscopy if it's not yearly endoscopy
anymore now it's like we'll check in
three years so that's good news but yeah
when like my my freak out over uh STD
scares and sent me running to the
gastroenterologist and uh
it's not the kind of like office where
it's like oh I saw Stevo at that place
is that I assume that's esophagus and is
that smoking caused or just hereditary
you know what I don't [ __ ] know I'm
not I think I I do know that acid reflux
is a big contributor yes exactly my
friend has it he has Cobblestone throat
Joe and uh he can't have spicy food he
can't have caffeine he can't have mint
oh God because all these I just sent him
like four cases of this hot sauce yeah
that that could [ __ ] him up but yeah my
ears have eaten [ __ ] yeah damn catches
up I'm fascinated because it's like
you've lived kind of on the edge for so
long in so many ways not just like this
stuff this outside stuff but your career
is kind of on the edge do you think
they're linked do you think like you
like it took so you took such risks in
life as a as a professional do you think
that the sex addiction and the other
addiction like it comes hand in hand hmm
I don't know I don't know about that
all right like I wouldn't say oh because
I'm like today maybe I'm I'm uh you know
a risk taker in my professional life it
spills over into my personal life if
anything I would say or the other way
around you know just a [ __ ] you know
loose screw [ __ ] nut job and and uh I
found a way to make a living at it hell
yeah you gotta love Showbiz yeah but
here's what I gotta ask so we like to
drink we like to party
uh you're sober flying straight beat the
sex addiction beat the booze beat the
drugs you guys clearly aren't having sex
is it boring are you gonna are you gonna
make it I mean it's it's hard to hang on
I am uh
absolutely [ __ ] psycho about
um
about work I think is what you know like
I just Channel it all into uh trying to
accomplish it I'm sure you guys are no
different yeah we work a lot but we also
play how many podcasts do you have you
said you told me you've got like you've
got two or three yeah so it's that's I
think we work a lot we get stressed out
we want to kill ourselves but
we also can take the edge off with a
nice high ball right I mean I basically
just never stopped working that's the
key I guess but how do you relax when
you do take your foot off the gas
um with my girl I would say I've had
about getting my girls over there
shaking her head he never takes his foot
off the gas like you don't ever just
have like a movie night or
um I mean I suppose that sometimes we'll
we can watch uh something on TV or
something but
um I I find that I'm busy enough that
it's uh
and I like being busy I do too but
sometimes it hits you yeah in my book I
uh like the last chapters from the
culmination of it all and and it starts
with the question in quotes are you
happy
and and I acknowledge that
for all the [ __ ] countless times that
I've been asked that question am I happy
for
countless years
it's just given me anxiety it's just
funny it's it's annoyed me it's been fun
it's just made me uncomfortable because
like like my gut reaction when I hear
that question like I can scan my body
like no I'm not [ __ ] happy I can I
can tell and like it's it's not uh like
in our society it's just not okay to
answer that because no I'm not happy
because it's like one thing like yeah
what's up man how's it going that's
totally different from are you happy of
course you know it's such a question
it's such a more invasive it's a great
question to ask though in the elevator
yeah are you happy right it's such an
invasive question and and uh you know I
kind of
like really uh
get into it and and um because it it
bothered me for a long time and and and
so I just I kind of asked myself why
does it bother me so much and when I
arrived at is that I I truly believe
that to be happy is essentially the
equivalent of to be content and if
you're content then by definition you
don't need anything so you become
[ __ ] lazy and that's what makes
losers
no I'm not [ __ ] happy I don't I'm I'm
a constant ball of stress and anxiety my
default uh mentality is that
everything's not okay and I'm not gonna
be okay and that I better [ __ ] hurry
up and and hustle and work to make it so
that everything might be okay yeah and
and that is just my my Perpetual state 8
and I would
you know if I if I could actually have a
choice
I would not choose to be [ __ ] happy I
choose the hustle you know I think you
can have both I I get what you're saying
but I think on the other end of it to be
depressed is to be crippled like you you
depression can be right right I'm not
talking about depression so you want
something in the middle I'm not talking
about depression I'm talking about like
sort of anxiety you know like the
feeling that's a motive for you it's a
fire under my ass you know like I just
feel like I'm not okay like uh I gotta I
gotta [ __ ] make [ __ ] happen and I do
not know how to turn that off like yeah
I'm similar I I wish that I could be
like okay I've worked and now I'm gonna
flip the switch Yeah it's gonna chill
same yeah last night was the first night
I took off in forever and I felt guilt
yes yes and I will say there was a part
of me that like obviously this is an
insane thing to say but like
sometimes I look at IGN you know people
who are ignorant ignorance is bliss so I
see someone on the street smiling I'm
like look at this [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah
it is more on smiling what are you happy
about you know I'm like wow what a dumb
observation but you know I see what
you're saying I'm not too far off of
that uh you know when I
submit that intelligence is a liability
sure you know like people dumb people
are way happier I think oh yeah yeah
because think about it like there's got
to be some dumb miserable people though
yeah
for sure
definitely yeah
you would imagine that uh intelligence
affords wisdom knowledge right but what
is there to know the history is a bunch
of bad [ __ ] news that's definitely
going to repeat itself the more you
learn the more [ __ ] much of a bummer
it is yeah but I think we look at not to
get schmaltzy but we look at happiness
like it's this big state like like being
in New York I live in New York but
happiness comes and goes it's not just
this all the time you know feeling it's
not something you're just sitting in
it's like today I'm happy or this hour
I'm happy the next hour I'm not I mean
we act like you have to be happy all the
time and then we think by hey I'll go to
Tijuana or I'll go to Bali and I'll be
happy but you're still there with your
[ __ ] up thoughts you gotta make it
happen you got to make yourself happy
you gotta practice gratitude I think
that's a big thing it's not just about
happy oh I'm not happy it's about what
are you doing to become happy and what
do you have in your life that you should
be happy about that you're not right we
just say happy like it's this General
thing don't worry about getting the
things you want worry about wanting the
things you have
oh yeah yes exactly I like this way this
is going man yes I I no I relate to that
and Mark and I talk about this a lot but
like sometimes you're in a funk and
you're like force yourself to go to the
gym like I'm not saying that is the
answer but it's there's stuff you can do
to help you know right I was feeling
this morning I was like I'm working out
you know I feel a little better yeah
sometimes the thing you want to do the
least is actually the thing you should
be doing yeah yeah it's easy to pick up
that cupcake
um so like that's my annoying homework
like uh I've got this bit and and I do
talk about it in my book about how I
used to try it and it would bomb it's an
unpopular uh topic all right
the bit was
and I would just come out and say this I
uh I have a theory that I might even say
I have an unpopular Theory I think God
hates us okay it's like oh you know like
like that was abrasive that kind of like
one like and then so now follow me okay
I like it follow me
um
we
human beings
are the only [ __ ] organism that got
[ __ ]
by the awareness
the hypothetical awareness no less
that
that we're gonna die and what's [ __ ]
up about that
we have but one instinct which is to
survive
and one guarantee which is we won't yeah
you got that right so
come on this is a [ __ ] a [ __ ] up
cruel prank on us the one [ __ ] thing
that we care about not happening is the
only thing that we know will happen
inevitable and as we barrel down this
[ __ ] dark and scary [ __ ] path
towards our inevitable demise
we Wilt we [ __ ] will our bodies
deteriorate they fail us they wrinkle
they bruise they Wilt this bit is going
to struggle on Fallon
I don't think I think they're going to
see you and they're like holy [ __ ] this
is kind of cerebral here
I I think that is actually the
popularity of Jackass is that you guys
are death-defying you're doing these
crazy stunts and I think also and living
so it's almost like you're saying like
it's kind of hard to die actually uh
perhaps I mean definitely like this uh
this whole existential [ __ ] crisis of
the you know The Human Condition yeah
and like oh my God this sucks like uh
we're gonna die you know like uh they're
there are two things about that that uh
what the [ __ ] man sex we gotta die and
so
people people address mortality in uh
three major ways that I identify number
one is they turn to religion because the
promise is that they're gonna go to
heaven and everything's gonna be great
so it's totally okay they're gonna die
yeah must be nice yeah to think that
yeah and dumb people we're gonna tell
you this is a Scientology podcast we'll
get you right okay that the second way
people uh you know wrap their head
around mortality is to reproduce they
feel like oh you know I might not be
here but the Family Jewels have done
their job my my uh bloodline my lifeline
the family name like I'm leaving my
legacy and my children and I'm not into
that either you know I got a vasectomy
you know and filmed it for uh a stunt
and you know with my girl we just don't
want to have kids yeah then the third
category
is people I like the caveman scrolling
the stick figures on the cave wall it's
like this [ __ ] I'm gonna be gone but
that [ __ ]
you know like we leave the [ __ ] behind
yeah which is what we're doing with our
act our specials our books exactly and
um I uh what was very much you know like
at the point when I really committed
myself to this uh pursuit of um you know
a Fame and being a crazy stunt man it
was 1993. I had failed [ __ ] miserably
at the University of Miami and because I
couldn't bring myself to go to class
yeah I couldn't help but get kicked out
of the dorms I upped and physically
that's also a school where it's probably
very tempting to party yeah yeah and and
I I didn't do well and and and I also
knew uh beyond a shadow of a doubt that
I could not keep a job like every job
that I ever had every job I ever had I
filled at Store bag got fired on like
every denomination of days right from
like one through seven I have a job
where I got fired on that day like I
could not I couldn't I couldn't get
through school and I couldn't keep jobs
so I was just confronted with this
realization that the likelihood was I
was going to fail at life and die
miserably young having failed and that
made me mad you know it made me mad and
I was like the one thing I love is video
cameras the one thing I want to do is if
I can be an attention [ __ ] with my
video camera I'm gonna film stupid
stunts and become a crazy famous stunt
man yeah and I didn't think I was gonna
have any success I didn't think it was
gonna work out I thought that what I was
doing was just trying to film the
craziest [ __ ] [ __ ] ever and
effectively
it's you know fill my message into the
bottle so that I could be discovered
yeah after I died having failed and
maybe be like the van Gogh of the home
video camera yeah yeah sure and and the
idea that I was going to [ __ ] die
having failed in life kind of pissed me
off and I think that that did inform my
choice to be doing this like death to
fight you know I was mad at [ __ ]
death I'm like look I'm gonna [ __ ]
jump up this rooftop and you're gonna
think maybe I'm gonna die because I'm
[ __ ] mad [ __ ] you death
yeah yeah cheating death taunting death
lashing out at death like that was very
very uh I really think this is the
popularity of Jackass I think you're
right I think people see that and
they're like the way like people like
we'll post like a Heckler video
sometimes and people [ __ ] love it
because I think it's like well I can't
tell off my boss so there's like some
weird Justice in this moment I think for
you guys it's the death definer like
well I'm too scared to do that that
right but I get to live vicariously
through you doing that and I get a
thrill watching that yeah it's the same
with Charlie Sheen who does you know
blow and [ __ ] porn stars your your
office job going wow look at this guy
he's living life and he came out the
other end and it's fun to watch I mean
he got AIDS but HIV HIV sorry yeah but I
think he was [ __ ] your ex
[Music]
but we'll get you one day Sheen yeah we
love you Shane but I'm just saying it's
fun to watch bucket list guests
but let me throw this at you because you
gotta do what you want you want a [ __ ]
up Charlie Sheen story oh boy absolutely
um now word from our sponsor better help
you have to take care of your mind folks
we spend so much time taking care of our
skin our hair our teeth and so little
care of the most important body part the
brain how well you take care of your
brain affects how you experience life
investing time and energy and mental
health is crucial to being happy eating
right working out and getting plenty of
sleep or a good start but no
substitution for talk therapy better
help makes online therapy accessible
convenient and affordable we love
therapy it's good for you don't let
those bags pile up everybody's got [ __ ]
in their life everybody's got drama you
gotta make it work you gotta be healthy
and that's how you do it is talking
about it that's how you get it out
better help is online there it offers
video phone and chat therapy sessions
you can choose to not see anyone on
camera and it's much more affordable
than in person you can be matched with a
therapist in under 48 hours we might be
drunk listeners get 10 off their first
month at betterhelp.com drunk that's b e
t t e r h e l
p.com slash drunk get on it fume is the
safe way to quit smoking fumes 100
Canadian maple handcrafted inhaler is
made to replace the hand-to-mouth Habit
simply insert their non-addictive
flavored cores uh fume cores come and
does the flavors like peppermint lemon
berry Bliss ooh yeah the flavors are
good they taste nice I love the little
pipe inhaler thing it's so cool fun to
suck on fun to put in your mouth there's
no smoke no vape and no nicotine to
worry about even if you're not trying to
quit smoking fumes core can help with
relaxation energy and more whether
you're a smoker or an ex smoker who
still struggles with Cravings fume is
the perfect tool for you it's time to
create positive habits and quit
naturally with fume and we're here to
make it easier head to fume.com drunk
use promo code drunk to save 10 off your
whole order save money by eliminating
cigarettes and save on your initial
purchase of fume that's 10 off your
entire order at
[Music]
b-r-e-a-t-h-e-f-u-m.com slash drunk and
use code drunk hey folks the summer
months are here time to stay fueled and
hydrated making hydration a priority
helps us feel healthier in our everyday
lives one stick of liquid IV and 16
ounces of water hydrates you two times
faster and more efficiently than water
alone liquid IV products taste great
with 10 refreshing flavors concord grape
lemon lime tropical Bunch my favorite
flavor is pina colada
if you like pina coladas usually would I
be first thing in the morning uh before
a workout when you feel run down after a
long night of boozing and just to manage
daily hydration the single serve
packaging helps keeps you hydrated while
on the go I put one in my uh water every
morning I just why the hell not I hung
over not hungover I do it B3 B5 B6 B12
vitamin C it's in my travel bag for sure
gotta have it we have it at the studio
we like to drink heavily as you know
it's in the title it's got more three
times more electrolytes than a
traditional sports drink liquid IV's got
no gluten dairy or soy and it's uh
designed to enhance rapid absorption of
water and other key ingredients into the
bloodstream tell them how to get it
Sammy grab your liquid IV in bulk
nationwide at Costco or you can get 15
off when you go to liquid iv.com and use
code drunk at checkout that's 15 off
anything you order when you shop better
hydration today using promo coated drunk
at liquid iv.com
was
was famously on the Charlie Sheen roast
The Comedy Central roast of Charlie
Sheen yeah and um
I uh
that like he had this little party
before the taping of the roast
to uh get everybody to like over to his
house
everybody meet each other and kind of
hang out and sort of maybe establish a
rapport before we tape the show very
cool of him
we're we're uh at his house and he kind
of he pulls me aside and he's like Steve
oh man
and mind you this was like right at the
kind of uh the the end of the Tiger
Blood Trail yeah yeah
he pulls me aside he says man Stevo dude
[ __ ] you and me why don't we go down
we're not [ __ ] around when we you
know like
we go down in flames like [ __ ] big
time like serious like we're you know
and uh and I felt like that that that
was a particularly bonding moment oh of
course we uh we we taped the the the
roast with you know
like it was great and then when the
roast aired
when the roast aired we uh were
invited bank robber to Charlie Sheen's
house for the the viewing party the
viewing viewing party and it was um I
think there's by design that they
premiered that Charlie Sheen roast uh
immediately nothing different networks
but immediately following the very first
episode of Two and a Half Men to feature
Charlie Sheen and not I tried to feed
your Ashton Kutcher and not Charlie whoa
and of course his relationship with the
Two and a Half Men production was frayed
of course and he was absolutely
oblivious to how they were gonna handle
the uh the the killing of his character
and the introduction and and I was in I
mean this was the half an hour before I
was there yeah yeah and and I was in his
list so you watched the episode with him
I've watched the episode with them in
his living room with him and I saw his
reaction to What to realize and what
they did with his character there was it
was like his character had died and like
here was an urn with all the ashes and
then somebody like jumbles the iron and
it flies up in the air and there's a
cloud of uh of the Ashes coming out of
the urn and as the cloud dissipates
Ashton Kutcher uh you know like yeah
like the the cloud dissipates and then
to reveal Ashton Kutcher behind the
ashes and he was like very subtle
and and Charlie says I got to give it to
him that was good
and a little later in the night a little
later in the night he sounds like a fun
hang you can't do totally totally a
little later in the night I uh I'm
talking to Jeffrey Ross and I just It
just strikes me I say I say to him I go
dude
I think we might actually be in the
world's most expensive crack house
what's this place like the most
expensive crack house on Earth and I
went running over to Charlie and uh took
a photo with him I was like oh two
accused yourself being and I'm like take
this up I still had my black eye from
running into Mike Tyson's Fist and um
Charlie just looked like she had in that
photo yeah we both looked like [ __ ] in
that photo but I was just so excited I
said Charlie can I tweet this photo yeah
with like uh the text it says I think
I'm in the most expensive crack house on
earth and he goes hilarious go for it
totally man I love it I'm like and uh
and and it was that that was not a hit
with this management
and and then the next morning I was
performing uh I like that weekend I was
at the like uh Ontario Improv or the
brand improv one of those like you know
like
one of those comedy clubs and I was at
the the news to to
um promote it and and some news person
that like uh
I've got this side thing here I'm gonna
film it on my cell phone and they asked
like is is Charlie sober hmm
oh and I was like
I don't think so and then later that day
I got a call from his manager saying
what the [ __ ] you're [ __ ] saying
Charlie's not sober oh boy like the [ __ ]
we had your back we were down with you
he was he [ __ ] Unleashed like a
tirade oh wow I've heard the tiger blood
has caffeine
I mean so in any case like uh I too can
can effectively I think just have
Charlie Sheen as a bucket list guest for
the rest of my life yeah because I got
the sense that uh I don't know I mean
maybe I've called him like maybe I'm
like he doesn't I didn't I didn't mean
no to do any harm that's manager
[ __ ] yeah Charlie he okayed the
picture too yeah well you said crack
house I said Craig give me what's the
rundown what's his place look like is it
crazy it was palatial yeah
it was looking obnoxiously palatable
yeah give me give me like what are the
rooms like
just massive I mean I've just saved it
to base it like when you think of a
palatial massive Mansion I mean it's
exactly what you would picture too yeah
yeah yeah if anything though like the
gated community that he lived in was uh
it did kind of feel a little bit like
all the houses looked very similar I'm
not gonna say cookie cutter all right
but it had a similar Vibe all to it got
it well let me just go back to the the
death thing because you got something in
my head here it's horrible it's
inevitable we're all gonna die and we
know we're gonna die which is a bummer
which means God hates us but isn't it
better to know because now we can live
damn it you know some Mongoose is just
like trying to survive trying to get a a
meal trying to survive and live and get
a Hut but we can do all this exercise
because we know there's an ending I
think you're on to something there and I
don't know if this falls into the
category of Comedy but there's
absolutely a very powerful message in in
uh
pointing out that that people go through
their [ __ ] life with blinders on it's
like they don't want to think about
don't remind me of my mortality
they do everything they can to not think
about it when in fact probably the the
way to have the most fulfilling and
meaningful life is to think about it
every day I agreed had to really be
deliberate about living every day
knowing about like like really focusing
on the finite nature of our existence
you're here but we talk about like you
know ignorance is blissed before and
that dog's wagging its tail because it
doesn't know yeah that's true if that
you don't see a lot of goth dogs
they're usually pretty like you know
upbeat that's true yeah right and they
can eat their own ass or they can blow
themselves that's pretty good too yeah
it's really pretty cool
can you blow yourself I cannot oh that's
shock I cannot it seems like
yeah I've tried too I pulled a muscle
um but yeah boy this is deep who know we
really yeah tackled some [ __ ] this is
great tackled how's that bit doing is it
working
um the God hates us I haven't
um I haven't worked on it in a long time
but I am
super committed to my next hour really
uh serving to explore this you know it's
kind of the premise of my next hour
because my next hour is going to be
uh well Sam's been replaced
that's hilarious my next hour will be an
exploration of uh my
my experience with confronting middle
age oh nice there you go the breakdown
of the physical body that I've relied on
for my livelihood well you got hair you
got teeth you thin I mean you're You're
Sober you're in a good place what things
physically thanks that's uh I'm gonna
I'm gonna hang on to that yeah yeah and
it's gonna clutch to that for dear life
and you gotta I I assume anxiety dog
because you're not blind right I mean
it's a service dog service dog but
what's the service well she's um
Mobility assist oh nice yeah cause I'm
not [ __ ] going anywhere without her
pal yeah yeah don't expect me to be very
mobile without her sis I need a hangover
dog like help me out when I'm hungover
like all right we're going to get you to
the gym you piece of [ __ ] the dog can't
touch said the n-word years ago and now
it's not allowed to speak but
all right we're having too much fun here
did I tell you honey how [ __ ] great
this guy is oh come on we go way back
I have nothing else in life except for
jokes so it's good man yeah and we get
to tell them you know a microphone to
hundreds of people we got it made yeah
hundreds of people and yeah we still get
sad yep but that's that's the brain it
it is it's a it's very uh relative you
know um they say that
so was it Einstein was it some [ __ ]
philosopher who said that that money has
never made a man happy that in fact
quite the opposite what money does is it
creates a void
where an insatiable void Mo Money Mo
Problems yeah well like the more money
you know like that uh you know it's
classic talk about marking your
territory
there you go right here perfect they uh
they did some survey I heard about they
they surveyed like
people with over 10 million bucks I mean
maybe people of all kinds of uh of um
financial status and they found that the
more money people have the more
financially insecure interesting
interesting that people with over 10
million dollars
in their bank account so Elon Musk must
be freaking out all the time you're
probably thinking about it yeah but
because you get knocked out of that like
top five right you're probably like [ __ ]
yeah I'm out I'm on the way out right
and and and I think that there there's a
saying that really illustrates that
which which kind of knocked me on my ass
which is that a man who has nothing
doesn't have to worry about anything
except his next meal but the man who has
everything has to worry about his last
meal is that [ __ ] up that's heavy
still leaning toward the billionaire
yeah
here's one that [ __ ] me up yeah every
man has two lives but his second life
starts when he realizes he only has one
oh I might have [ __ ] that up no I
think that makes sense okay like he once
you accept your mortality yeah you're
really living I did not realize you'd be
doing so much death toll I know this is
heavy it's great it's nice good to get
it out because everybody thinks it's a
magic pill you can just take and it'll
all work out but you gotta work at it
you gotta like somebody wants to like oh
I want to learn another language but
it's so much work and I want to get
buffed but it's I gotta go to the gym I
want it to be easy but it should be hard
because that's the fun part like earning
it very little of supreme value is uh
easy to exactly yeah
um so Mark asked me
um he just said so going back to the
death thing yes how'd that how'd the bit
go you know how's it been going and um
candidly I've not really worked on the
you know the
existential crisis bit about death in
some time but I'm very much committed to
my next hour that I put together really
being
uh
an exploration of my experience with
confronting middle age the breaking down
of the body that I rely on for my
livelihood like the the [ __ ] you know
it's not like middle-aged [ __ ]
no matter who you are that sucks for all
people
yeah for Stevo right it's like it's
extra [ __ ] up you know of course this
is gonna be rough it's 78. yeah you know
so I really do need to to to work on
this bit and get it so yeah and then
like what I do with my comedy it's it's
multimedia like right now I'm on the
bucket list tour and each item on the
list is a bit in the show and at the
after the bit I screen the footage of
the culmination of the bit oh that's
great I pay off every bit with an actual
video of the [ __ ] up thing I did that
I just told you the hilarious story
about right oh that's interesting that's
great and so I plan to do the same thing
with my next tour
and kind of going down like the list of
the different like major concerns that
uh middle age has confronted me with
um
impotence
now I I've been fortunate that that uh
impotence isn't always a problem yeah no
one's perfect right
um but like the one thing
um
I got [ __ ] man titties dude this is
the middle age deal I don't see it
there's dimples dude really oh my God
I'm developing [ __ ] man titties dude
see like dimples
dude I'm sorry man but I have [ __ ]
underboob and it's driving me nuts and
and my uh my my feelings about this just
because I want to raise the bar for
crazy I wanna like the god that [ __ ]
[ __ ] me and now has has relegated me
to [ __ ] walking around with man tits
oh I'm lashing out at that God and
getting breast augmentation surgery hell
yeah yeah that's gonna be one of my
things when I'm getting [ __ ] double d
tits I'm sure she loves this she's back
and forth with it all right I mean
they're fun
this is like half a transition yeah
you're going like I'm just gonna do the
tits that was my dad like ever the
homophobic he said and uh how long are
you gonna wait until you do the bottom
half
I'm just gonna be meatloaf in Fight Club
fun stuff to do with that in my view
sure like there's so many great bits to
you could clean up on only fans yeah
tits I'd pay for that yeah for sure
and I consulted with the
the person I believe is the world's most
famous plastic surgeon of botched Fame
oh Dr Terry Dubrow okay he says don't
keep him in for more than three months
and then the stretching will be
manageable he can really put me back
together okay so uh three months you'll
be by for three months yeah that my my
girl her name is Lux she says I will be
in Europe for three months it's a good
time to take a vacation yeah so you're
really gonna do this yeah dude I'm
absolutely I'm sure I'm gonna do this
well now you got your closer for the new
hour yeah wow that's not the closer oh
really wow yeah that's definitely not
the closer but uh but yeah it's
everything about what I'm seeking to do
oh wow so we were donating some implants
so that's gonna be your future yeah dude
epic yeah why not everything about what
I'm I'm seeking to do with the next hour
is challenging I love it challenging the
confronting mortality like alienating
um I love you doing heady material with
just big cans on stage you're like
what's up with God
I think that I will have been restored
to normal yeah before that before
actually going on the road right right
yeah uh part of me thinks dude don't
[ __ ] half-ass it you little [ __ ] you
know keep the tits for the whole tour
yeah my girl didn't want to hear that
are you going d double D's when I got Dr
Terry Dubrow said I can do D or double D
oh my Lord there's a there there's a
Saving Grace of middle age that uh my
man titties are [ __ ] malleable and
and uh I have potential what about a
dick implant not a dick implant tattoo
on my forehead the one oh yeah no don't
do that yeah I love that that bothers
you more my girl has absolutely no
problem with the dick tattoo really
because you're still a man you see
because back to my uh my my
uh formulaic approach to this you know
everything needs to be motivated and in
my view
the wrinkles that are accumulating
around my eyes and on my face in general
are not [ __ ] okay but once I get a
big dick tattooed on my forehead that's
all anybody's gonna be able to see so so
I will be young again which the
housewives would do that yeah
geez the dick but that that's
unremovable no it is that laser laser
tattoo removal and it's counterintuitive
but the one color of tattoo ink which
comes out most easily and completely is
black ah so you have a black dick yeah
finally you'll be satisfied
now she's gonna really want to sit on
your face
yeah you're in an interracial
relationship about these guys honey
they're [ __ ] great fantastic
yeah dude we can't take a couple not now
I want you guys to know that as annoying
as it was having homework for this
podcast I did do it oh all right well
really what do you got well I mean uh
like we've we've we've thrown out more
bits you got a bit out there since throw
out but appreciate that I'm the kind of
guy who who can actually
um cough up his ideas because nobody's
[ __ ] taking my ideas
I I can comfortably put it out there
into The Ether and know that nobody's
gonna steal it I know you and Maria
Bamford
right now
do you have a peeve a pet peeve you know
what the the one thing that really came
to mind
is when I I see it [ __ ] so often dude
is when someone says I was so glad to be
a part of it but a part is one word oh
oh how about a part of something yeah a
part it's a different meaning right yeah
it's not only a different meaning it's
the exact [ __ ] opposite meeting a
part of it oh I'm so glad I'm so glad
that I got to be a part of it when
they're saying a part is one word not a
part whoa you're both because apart when
the words are together the letters are
together it means it means far away
separate apart but if you make two words
out of it it is a part so it's part
completely [ __ ] opposite I feel like
just it irks the [ __ ] out of me yeah
when it's when I see that like now you
are not a you're not a part of it we
love you being a part of this podcast
yeah when you get the tits
man that's a good one a parts that's
good apartheid yeah it's just a a silly
[ __ ] little thing but it but it irks
the [ __ ] out of me the English language
is a real [ __ ] like imagine trying to
learn the English language late in life
you know it's like we have we have a
thing called a dress shirt you know we
say he's pretty ugly I mean it's so
[ __ ] up Twisted link Linguistics in
English
pretty ugly what's wrong with the dress
shirt well it's a dress shirt but it's a
shirt ah so it's confusing maybe if
you're a foreign
good friend of mine one of my best
friends he'll do this a lot he'll just
say I don't know why it bugs me so much
but it'll say I had a great time uh
giggling with you last night giggling
the [ __ ] you I hate that
Asian and teenage girl what the hell
that sounds like a very homophobic peeve
really giggling no I don't think it's a
he's a straight guy it's more childlike
weird giggling I'm like what are we
children yeah giggling I I have the same
thing when a guy will write back he he
how about a ha ha
giggling just sounds like we're like
what were we doing last night we had a
real good giggle yeah
a real belly giggle yeah I picked you
guys holding each other get in here bro
yeah kill a giggle
with one fine giggle dude oh that's a
good one yeah you keep joking I'll bring
the giggles yeah we'll see you next week
not now I recently put a video together
of 10 things that really pissed me off
oh hit us dude ah and
um
[ __ ] urinals was big on the list I
mean what the [ __ ] dude like
well you just want a regular toilet I
mean just I sit down to pee yeah oh
really yeah I sit down to pee because
all [ __ ] standing up to pee is is
just an exercise and pissing all over
the [ __ ] place yeah like I mean dude
like it's so absurd that they actually
put like special mats for collecting
piss on the floor in front of the urinal
right because they know they know they
know that this is just gonna this is
just a [ __ ] Battle Zone of [ __ ]
yeah I wear these pants they're very
nice but look one one inch of liquid and
you got Mouse could jizz on these and
you would see it and I was at the urinal
yesterday and I was all I had the back
spray and it was like I had to sit down
and do this [ __ ] for a half an hour
while it dried because the backsplash
was so bad but with jeans you don't
really notice it but with these pants
how about this when when women become
irate because you left the seat up oh my
God okay like think about this no good
dude the guy the guy that these women
are getting mad at had the
forethought the courtesy the decency to
not piss on that [ __ ] right he lifted
the seat so as to not piss on it and he
left it up as a sign of that courtesy
and that respect right
whereas the other guy never [ __ ] put
it up in the first place pissed all over
it and the lady's like oh what a
gentleman right I don't think they say
what a gentleman if it's covered in fish
right right maybe he [ __ ] uh did a
slap Dash job of wiping it off so it's
not visible but it's covered up pissed
yeah no it's a good point I do the uh
foot I pee on the seat and then I use a
sock that's my move I don't know if you
guys know that so that the whole like
standing after standing up to piss thing
like I had especially because when I get
I want him on the airplane I take off my
shoes I would rather have my shoes off
and then I go to the bathroom and and
the the flight attendants are disgusted
by me they're like oh my God you're
going into the bathroom right like
Barefoot or in your socks have you not
seen Jackass have you not seen the [ __ ]
I've Done Right going in there it's so
disgusting I'm like well how about this
like I personally out of respect IP
sitting down because I don't want to be
one of these guys pissing all over
everything I go into the bathroom
Barefoot and that's nothing compared to
when I sit down on the toilet
I'm sitting in some [ __ ] asshole's
piss yeah that's a lot more disgusting
than what's going on with my feet flight
pissing is a real peeve of mine because
I'm first off I'm tall I I have to sit
down
oh my God I'm dude on the on those
little planes I can't my neck's already
[ __ ] up I can't I can't stand upright
what's wrong with your neck I just have
some disc there degenerative disc
disease me too sucks right yes yeah man
all right you know what's fun I used to
get I went to a basketball camp when I
was 17. and all the black kids call me
Stevo because I had a shorter haircut
cool yeah they're like Stevo huh are you
better looking than me oh I don't know
dude I don't know about that but I I do
it's funny he went to camp and they
called him jewfaced
um another thing that [ __ ] pisses me
off and it pisses me off in a serious
way is cemeteries
oh think about this okay
when you bury a dead human being yeah
what you have done is
you have taken a plot of land and
rendered that piece of land utterly
[ __ ] useless for feeding people for
Sheltering people like you've just
you've just [ __ ] completely
disqualified that land for being of any
use and on top of that you've made
you've not made that land creepy oh
that's great with George Carlin has a
whole bit about this but I go to my
grandparents grave sometimes I'm like
this could have been a [ __ ] Walgreens
for sure yeah exactly and um spooky is
interesting and then the the whole
life cycle the the the the nature of of
Life Everything Changes right you've
done that to this land [ __ ] forever
so like you know Generations go by
Generations go by and then now like like
all the world is a [ __ ] Cemetery now
it's true and it goes on and on forever
it's just never like you're stunt in
growth yeah in a way you're not Stuntin
growth you're you're [ __ ] like
who live near a cemetery that's nice
you're in a quiet neighborhood that's
true that is kind of nice that's true
and New Orleans cemeteries are like a
big deal people walk through them
there's like a tourist thing but during
Katrina a lot of the graves rose up yeah
which is like horror movie [ __ ] yeah and
so a lot of uh we have mausoleums
because of our flooding is so bad
right yeah I just think it's [ __ ]
stupid now the solution to this
is pretty cool all right I think Two and
a Half Men nailed it by the way yeah
right for them yeah cremation yeah I
think cremation's solid but they also
have
um what's called uh I think it's called
a tree pod where it's like that you can
fit the [ __ ] body of your loved one
in like a fetal position in this
egg-shaped pod which you do bury in the
ground and it turns into a tree whoa
that's way better way better well I
think Aloo bell used to have a bit like
why do we bury ourselves lying down as
opposed to standing it would take up
less space
good a good angle yeah it's just [ __ ]
stupid it'd be funny if the tree came
out looking like like us like you're a
palm tree
[Laughter]
yeah super cheap funeral okay dude how
annoying is it the [ __ ] uh all these
gofundme's for [ __ ] funeral costs I
know the caskets are so expensive yeah
crazy
that open casket is such a weird
tradition yeah yeah dude yeah the queen
they lined up dude yeah did you see that
the image of the body in the fetal
position [ __ ] in the Pod I mean it's
very symbolic it's like kind of how you
come into the world in fetal position
right and then you and you go out yeah
there you go oh look at that there you
go
yeah we should be doing this this is
a lot of people at morgues who are like
look he's sucking his dick but you're
right it's like he's in a ball bag and
he's gonna come out as a tree yeah a
kumquat all right sorry
inside do we cover all of my homework I
got the peeves you crushed it man yeah
oh things that we recommend oh you're we
weren't gonna push for it but we're
honored okay things that we record
besides fake tits I can
I cannot [ __ ] I was good if I was
gonna say that we're all podcasters here
so let's uh take this opportunity to
make ourselves some money let's talk
about tushy
which I absolutely do recommend do you
use it I [ __ ] use it yes you have it
on there I have it but my I literally
you guys promoted
not to use it I should use I would love
to have a bidet my [ __ ] is a
graveyard of yeah [ __ ] yeah I mean
Crustaceans on that butthole terribly
yeah like uh yeah I really Amish I
cannot recommend the use of a bidet
enough you're not all kidding aside like
I love to promote tushy now here's what
a maniac I am on my podcast when I'm
promoting tushy I
out loud into a microphone identify them
as my favorite sponsor which is
actually saying all the rest of the
sponsors of my podcast can go [ __ ]
suck a fart out of my [ __ ] because
I'm giving preferential favor to tushy
all right and I can't help it because
I'm an honest guy I hear you I [ __ ]
love tushy everybody should be doing it
we have stuff in our butt cracks all day
long that we don't know about it's out
of sight out of mind but it's better to
get that cleaned up I'm definitely probe
a day I I just haven't set it up
in lieu of uh now I I will I will toilet
I will I will say something uh something
somewhat critical which is that until
she also sells a uh it's I think it's
called tushy on the go and it's like a
collapsible squeeze water bottle
you uh flip up the nozzle and you're
supposed to like sort of reach between
your legs and legs squeeze the water
bottle and spray it I don't find that
super effective
and uh yeah
and uh and Lou of actually having the
proper bidet set up on the toilet like I
swear by [ __ ] flushable wet wipes oh
people love it I use those next one we
do yeah next month I will I'll be
receiving the first shipment of 10
000 50 packs of what Stevo's butt wipes
for your butthole
how are your butt wipes different than
like a standard one like the dude wipes
yeah for starters dude wipes is very
misogynistic okay like I mean dude I'm
not alienating anybody dear women have
buttholes too I love it bro yeah you're
starting some beef here yeah it's
starting some beans are they scented or
no uh my mine are not scented but God do
they feel great I can't wait I can't you
know what I'm gonna get these dude and I
have to say public apology my ex would
swear by these and I was always like Ugh
and then we broke up and I started using
them and she was right
the dry toilet paper does not do the
trick no it's not do the trick and and
like invariably like an hour later I
gotta go find a bathroom and wipe my ass
again and there's [ __ ] [ __ ] on the
toilet paper yeah yeah not cool man I
hate it it's true the girl shot on your
chest you wouldn't use a dry rag rag
don't ask me how I know
right well that would never I'm too
hairy for that to even be a possibility
like peanut butter and a garbage I mean
come on look at this oh yeah that's true
what wouldn't be this is the most
cleavage we've shown in a podcast
between me and Steve over here what
wouldn't be impossibility with the hairy
chest oh my God I mean I can [ __ ] on
there really
all right anybody could anybody could
[ __ ] on there what's what's getting it
off yeah with dry toilet paper you got a
problem
but not with Stevo's butt wipes yes butt
wipes for your butthole it's like a
whole kind of a line that I'm I'm going
I've got hot sauce for your butthole
butt wipes for your butthole yeah yeah
this is all under my company name I've
got a special company called Whole Foods
I love this video
without the W I love it I was thinking
if ands or butts
but this is great all right we got a
wreck we gotta pee we got a bit Stevo
you killed it man hey man you know I'm
uh I'm a neurotic homework doer I love a
hard kick in the Nazi where do you any
bookstore Amazon yeah
I mean it sounds awesome so that's
awesome
it is it is uh shocking what I [ __ ]
admit in that book I will say that oh
that's a good tease I can't wait yeah
this looks awesome yeah awesome man yeah
I enjoy you guys you're the best too man
thank you and that's a high compliment
because on my first date with with my
girl who's now my fiance that I said I
enjoy you whoa
all right
you got some tour dates coming on oh
yeah where are you gonna be Stevo these
next dates I don't know how soon you
guys are getting this up yeah I don't
either probably late October there you
go okay rather than Canada we're talking
to you hell yeah got a big run going
through Easter no sorry western Canada
okay what's the site name
oh it's just Steve oh man oh perfect
stevo.com stevo.com check it out for
dates go see him on the road he's
working on his new new hour I won't be
working on my new hour this is the
bucket list oh sorry this is the bucket
list tour this is where you're gonna see
uh you're all over look at that Jesus
Christ you're going hard ooh New York
town hall that's that's a great classic
I'm touring my [ __ ] living dick off
yeah go see those tits folks
hell yeah man thank you guys thank you
sir butt wipes wow what an episode with
Steve he's such a great guest uh coming
up killer uh I guess it's coming out
late October right so I'll be in New
Jersey at the stress Factory OKC right
after Norman's wedding uh Springfield
Missouri Fort Wayne Indiana Kansas
Missouri Tacoma Spokane big tour coming
in January I've been [ __ ] coming
everywhere so get ready for that
announcement too if if I haven't made it
already come all over me
I think that's sigura's tour I'm coming
everywhere that's a great great title
that's the hard thing that's coming up
with a tour what's your tour called all
over the road that's good you know I'm
all over the road it's got a double
meaning yeah double meaning's big for
that stuff yeah huge but coming
everywhere it's just so silly it's great
uh I'm I'm all over the road I'm in
Lincoln Nebraska I'm in Minneapolis I'm
in Seattle Portland uh Seattle again
Vancouver Houston New Orleans Boston New
Haven uh Philadelphia
Honolulu Nashville Miami you name it all
kinds of fun stuff It's gotta be a it's
gonna be a hell of a year uh new hours
cooking and uh yeah get on the patreon
get a mug get a shirt get a mark now
when he's cooking that hour it's gonna
be killer and uh get that Bodega cat
whiskey a bodega catwhiskey.com watch my
Netflix special please yes uh you know
you see us on the road yeah we got tons
of great guests cooking we got hours on
on YouTube we got a lot of content out
there for you folks and we love you
we'll see you next time at the
[Music]
bare juice
[Music]
dangerous
[Music]
after lunch here in New Orleans this
woman doesn't look like I remember her
and I get down in the same way
[Music]